claramente en la norma está que lo que
intentó el expresidente Castillo
fue un acto ilegal que está sancionado
por la Constitución
se han manifestado en contra el mismo
día en horas la verdad y las fuerzas
armadas el poder judicial la fiscalía la
defensoría del pueblo y en ese contexto
es que el congreso
cambia lo que era la la propuesta
inicial de de vacancia que era más bien
polémica es así pero la cambia
justamente por haber
llevado adelante un acto de rebelión
sancionado por la Constitución y lo van
vacado con votos incluso de gente de
izquierda entonces este son ciento diez
votos
que han determinado este su vacancia así
que
en ese sentido Claro entiendo que hay
voces disidentes pero en general Este
creo que
lo que hizo Castillo fue un acto digamos
que iba contra la Constitución y
Y pues lo único que quedaba ahí era
sancionarlo con la vacancia no
ha pedido asilo político a México pero
como lo dijimos previamente el
expresidente está detenido en esta
circunstancias puede realmente aspirar
al asilo
Mira yo no soy experto en temas
internacional pero pero
dificulto que que tenga esa opción
porque el asilo es un derecho político y
acá es lo que hay es una
aceptación a la constitución en el Perú
se pena entre diez y veinte años
entonces veo difícil que tenga ese
derecho porque no es que haya o no sea
un presidente que se encuentra
perseguido políticamente acá ha violado
la ley
y otra de las noticias del día es que
Dina boluarte de la presidenta de Perú
se mostró abierta por primera vez a
convocar a elecciones previas qué tan
factible Es que esto ocurra Y si
realmente así se solucionaría la crisis
política una crisis que ya se dio en
2019 y con la que también respondieron
con elecciones previas
Sí bueno justamente la lección del 2019
fue que solamente convocar a elecciones
no sirve para nada
lo que está en la agenda uno es mejorar
la gestión del estado y con este
presidente Lamentablemente un copamiento
una lógica de poteo en la gestión
pública que ha llevado a que el estado
que era un estado frágil débil con poca
capacidad de gestión se vuelve mucho más
frágil todavía y hay una serie de
urgencias vinculadas a salud
sequía etcétera
dos es una reforma política que
fundamental y recién tres es un eventual
convocatoria elección No pero si reforma
política no va a servir de nada Hernán
Chaparro analista político de Perú
Gracias por estar con nosotros